hi guys this is lucky and today I would
be covering up the concept of cloud
computing architecture but before that I
would request you guys to subscribe our
video channel along with that you can
like our video you can find the details
just below our video now let's look into
what we have for today's session so
today we would be covering up why we
require cloud computing what is cloud
computing technology what are the
benefits of cloud computing and the two
main architecture pillars of cloud
computing along with that and their
components of the cloud computing
technology
now why do we require cloud computing
let's look into it so earlier what was
happening before the cloud computing
technology the organizations were facing
some challenges challenges in terms of
on trim infrastructure so on prim
infrastructure on prim set up is
expensive it is less scalable because
you have already procured the
infrastructure so the scalability
becomes lower along with that they
require a lot of huge space for the
servers if in case you have lost data in
the on-prem it becomes difficult to
recover them along with that it takes
long deployment times apart from that
the other challenges were the lack of
flexibility poor data security less
collaboration with the inter
infrastructure and the data cannot be
accessed remotely the data can be
accessed remotely but there were some
challenges in terms of the security now
all these challenges were basically
overcome when the cloud computing
technology was introduced so before
cloud computing a managing files on a
local storage was also difficult but
with the introduction of cloud computing
what we caught we saw that there is no
server space required so nothing needs
to be set up in the on-prem
infrastructure no expose required for
hardware and software maintenance
because that would be done by the cloud
computing vendor itself it gave a better
data security and the disaster recovery
setup is fantastic in terms of the cloud
computing technology along with that
ease of deployment the deployment
activities become are easier in terms of
setting up on the cloud computing
platforms it is cost effective you
pay-as-you-go there are on-demand
services management of services easy as
well as the collaboration is also
efficient so cloud computing is
generally better than the on-prem
infrastructure because of so many
advantages it has now we have seen the
advantages of the cloud computing
why the organization's opted for the
cloud computing but what is actually the
cloud computing technology is so cloud
computing is basically the delivery of
on-demand resources so anything which
you need that is available so such as
server database software and they are
accessible over the internet so here in
the diagram you can see that a computer
or desktop can access any service over
the Internet so it's basically related
to server database and the software's it
also gives the ability to build design
and manage applications on the cloud
platform now you just have to note that
company is offering these computing
services are called as set allowed
providers so like AWS Google Cloud these
are all the cloud providers the cloud
computing service providers are called
as the vendors they provide services to
manage the applications through a global
infrastructure or a global network some
of the examples as I mentioned EWS
Microsoft Azure as well as Google cloud
so these are the three primary cloud
providers in the market let's look into
what are the benefits of using the cloud
computing
it is easily upgraded sometimes the
upgrades are managed by the vendor
itself so there are no hassles in terms
of doing the upgrades it is cost
efficient since these are on-demand
services so you pay as you use or you
pay as you go the scalability some is
almost you can say unlimited depends on
the setup or the infrastructure of a
cloud vendor and you can scale as much
as you require and it provides you lot
of services where you can do the
automation so you can basically create
your applications and you can automate
them you can even deploy your
application using the automation it is
highly available the reason is that they
have a redundant infrastructure so you
can create or deploy your applications
which will be highly available flexible
so you can shift between the services
you can shift between the infrastructure
whenever you
along with that it gives you the better
security in terms of managing your
applications along with the databases
and you can do the customization as per
your requirement now let's understand
what do we mean by the cloud computing
architecture so this diagram represents
the cloud computing architecture where
you can see there is a cloud
infrastructure which we call as a
front-end front-end means the
infrastructure that is network facing
that is internet facing and the backend
is where actually the application the
services and the devices are like
storage servers and all along with the
management and the security portals so
primarily the cloud computing
architecture has two components one is
the front-end and the other one is the
back end now with respect to the
architecture and the cloud computing is
architecture as we discussed earlier is
divided into two parts front end and the
back end it provides applications and
interfaces that are required for the
cloud based services so front end would
be anything which is facing the internet
for example the websites that you deploy
they are front-end because they are
accessed by the public over the public
network these applications basically
such as web browser Google Chrome and
Internet Explorer over which you can
basically open up your web applications
your web sites and also it includes
client and mobile devices along with
some api's so this is with respect to
the front-end architecture now let's
look into thee furthermore concepts
related to the front end so in the front
end the cloud infrastructure consists of
a hardware and the software components
that includes a data storage server
virtualization software etc also it
provides the GUI we call it as a
graphical user interface to the end
users so that they can perform the
respective tasks so it's a GUI based
access and those who are not from the
coding background or they don't have
familiarity with the CLI it is an
advantage
now let's understand the backend
architecture so the backend is basically
it manages all the programs that runs
the application on the front-end so
whatever is required to support the
applications for example web
applications which are running on a
front-end would be available in the
backend it has the larger number of data
storage systems and server so it is
basically it comprises of the entire
infrastructure of a cloud provider and
it can also be a software or it can be a
platform as well so based on the
requirement the application provides
output to the end users in the backend
also it is one of the most important
components in the cloud because it is
you can say a backbone of a cloud
computing architecture and its task is
to provide utility in the architecture
and the few services that are widely
used among the end-users are storage
application development environments and
the web services in the backend with
respect to the storage it maintains and
manages any time of any amount of data
over the Internet
some of the examples of storage services
on the cloud are s3 which is called as a
simple storage service Oracle cloud
storage and Microsoft Azure storage the
storage capacity varies depending upon
the service providers available in the
market and also it allocates specific
resources to a specific task
it handles functions of cloud
environment so this is with respect to
the management in the backend
architecture the management in the
backend architecture helps in the
management of components like
applications tasks service security data
storage in the cloud infrastructure and
in simple terms it establishes
coordination among the resources coming
to the security aspect of a back-end in
architecture it is an integral part of a
crowd infrastructure because since you
it mostly relies on the storage and the
databases so it has to be more secure it
in protecting cloud resources system
files and the infrastructures also it
provides security to the cloud servers
with virtual firewalls and results in
the prevention data loss now the
different components of the cloud
computing architecture one is the
hypervisor second is the management
software the third one is the deployment
software fourth one is the network fifth
one is the cloud server and you have the
cloud storage now let's look into what
we have with the hypervisor hypervisor
as the name suggests it's a virtual
operating platform and that is basically
used by every user it runs a separate
virtual machine on the back end which
consists of a software and the hardware
also it maintain objective is main
objective is to divide and allocate
resources so basically the hypervisor is
primarily used to virtualize the
physical machines so that it can be
shared across with many resources or
many users the management software its
responsibility used to manage and
monitor the cloud operations so all the
operational tasks are basically done by
the management software it helps in
improving the performance of the cloud
since you can do the admin tasks as well
for example high security flexibility
full-time access and the access given to
other users who would be working on the
cloud platform the deployment software
consists of all the mandatory
installations and configurations that
are required to run a cloud service
every deployment of cloud service is
performed using our deployment software
so it is primarily used for deploying
the applications or a software so that
basically saves the time of a developer
in terms of deploying their course now
the three different models which can be
deployed are the software as a service
which we call as a SAS so the software
as a service means it hosts the software
and manage the application of the
end-user example is Gmail so Gmail is an
example of a SAS service where it acts
as a mailing service and the users just
have to create their email accounts and
start using the service
the pass is basically a platform as a
service and it helps to develop and
build and deploy the applications on the
software primarily used by the coders
and they can concentrate more on their
development activities and less focus on
the infrastructure part example is
Microsoft ratio and the infrastructure
as a service is is basically to provide
services on pay-as-you-go pricing model
coming to the component of a cloud
computing architecture that is network
so what is with respect to network why
do we need a network so it connects the
front end and the back end together so
the network can be the internal private
network of a cloud computing provider as
well as the public network and also it
allows every user to access the cloud
resources over the Internet it helps
users to connect and customize the route
and protocols so let's say an admin
wants a particular IP s to be blocked so
you can specify them and customize them
in the route and the protocols it is a
virtual server which is hosted on the
cloud computing architecture so it is
just like a virtual networking that is
available on the cloud computing
platform it is highly flexible secure
and cost-effective and it is basically
you can say the backbone in terms of
connecting multiple services together
the cloud storage is basically made
every data is stored and that can be
accessed by a user from anywhere over
the Internet
of course it depends on how do you
provide the access to it it is scalable
at runtime and it is automatically
accessed and the data can be modified
and retrieved from the cloud storage
over the Internet itself so this was
about our session for today guys thank
you for watching this video I hope you
liked it
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here